dublin was a place on sunset basically
we're dane
really i got a great story about dublin
dude by the way
dublin dublin dane got his start when he
came out to l.a it was dangerous
it was dayne's night though like when
you shoot days yes
kind of went away dublin's took over and
that was dane spot
oh my god but it was also that place
if you did not get that crowd in the
first minute
it was gonna be a rough set for you
really
oh my [ __ ] god they because they were
young
chatty white people yeah and so they
were uh
you know and there was a lot of attitude
and if you didn't get them up front they
were just turning to each other and
[ __ ] talking
what do you got about dublin so i heard
about it so i went up there
and uh so i went up the first week i did
it i went up right before dane
and i think somebody made a phone call i
don't know if it was bobby lee or
something
and they was like get gary on he vouched
for me
so i went right before dane and i did
good
and then dame went up and that's when he
hit me go oh this is the guy they're
here to see because this ford name
really popped yeah right
then i came they said hey come you want
to come back next week i go yeah so come
back next week
and literally i'm supposed to go up
right before dane again at the last city
dane's got a ghost where he's gonna go
up you're gonna go up after him so i
don't know this is dane's room so in my
mind i'm like great
when that [ __ ] said good night
it was like
it was starting to leak uh
i still gotta and here's this buddy so
when i say
they're paying no attention to me it was
like they said good night and i think
the bartender rang the bell like it's
time to party
right so i'm up there nobody's paying
attention to me and i'm going
but i i had like this one table it was
like four dudes they're
dying they're like still at the comedy
club and i'm like
and i go well uh i would say thank you
but i don't think anybody heard me
tonight and then one guy goes literally
this guy goes
don't give up dude you're [ __ ] funny
don't give up
i was like what like i'm already a
headliner
and and like they were almost
aggressively
anti whoever else was if you got him you
got him but they were
not gonna give you anything i know a lot
of people have their issues with dane
because there's so much history there
i don't know where you guys sit with
dane but he's always for whatever reason
he's always been great to me
i've had to follow him he's always been
phenomenal to me and then
you know i know him because he was so
big when i was like in college in high
school he's so
he's like the kevin hart of now right he
was so [ __ ] big
but what people don't like there's all
this hate on dane
but when you see you know dane has some
skills man and i've seen dane
[ __ ] destroy rooms at the time story
hecklers
hecklers and do 30 minutes on just the
crowd and
wreck the room dude but you forget how
long he's been doing
everybody's another place talk about
dave not to cut you off but i just did
it
sorry uh he was getting ready to host
snl
geez so i was at caroline's that weekend
now my audience is black
i don't think his manager knew coming in
so they literally called me
hey you mind if dane goes up for fives
he's working on his monologue for snl
thursday and friday and i go yeah i
don't care so he came thursday
and that it was all black so his
monologue for snl wasn't his act because
he's working on his monologue
it just wasn't going over he didn't come
back friday
oh let's go let's try another room yeah
let's go
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son